Scientists in South Korea have converted cigarette
butts into material that coats the electrodes
of super capacitors for extremely large amounts
of energy storage.
And this a vampire plant sweet talks its victims
through DNA into lowering their defenses,
allowing it to tap into them and drain their
fluids.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
It turns out most people have herpes.
In the U.S. it’s estimated that 54% of 14-49
year olds have Herpes Simplex 1 and the worldwide
estimate of HSV-1 (the oral type) and HSV-2
(the genital type) is somewhere between 65%
and 90%!
Most people never shown signs of it because
flareups can depend on the strain and the
strength of host’s immune system.
And estimates on the older population having
the herpes virus are over 90%.
The Hyperlapse makes your action footage look
like a first person video game.
It smoothes out time-lapse first person video
that’s normally unwatchably shaky by using
an algorithm that estimates the camera path,
removes redundant frames, and then renders
a new stitched image blending it all together.
And Microsoft is currently working to make
this publicly available as an app.
The New Horizons NASA probe recently captured
video of Pluto and its largest moon, Charon
- this is the closest imaging of Pluto ever
- 10 times closer to it than Earth is.
And they’re planning on getting even closer
in January.
The BugJuggler is a 70ft tall robot that juggles
cars.
Or at least that’s the plan.
Dan Granett is building a proof-of-principle
arm that will juggle 250 lb cast iron weights
that will be controlled by a person wearing
a sensor sleeve and glove.
The glove provides haptic feedback - that
way they can feel the weight of the juggled
object.
With the ultimate goal of building a giant
robot that juggles VW Bugs.
Because...why not?
Researcher at MIT recovered sound from recording
video of a bag of chips.
The visual microphone uses a high speed camera
to pick up the incredibly subtle vibrations
on an object’s surface and then those are
extracted to partially recover the sound that
caused them.
For instance, here’s audio of a kid singing
recovered from video of a foil wrapper near
the child at the time.
Someday you may be able to power your phone
with sweat.
A wearable device similar to a temporary tattoo
features a sensor that measures lactate which
is produced by sweating.
It strips electrons from the lactate to generate
electrical current which is then stored by
a biobattery.
Currently, only a tiny amount of power can
be harnessed this way but they’re working
on increasing that so we can eventually power
a heart rate monitor or a smart phone.
This real-time facial tracker with projection
mapping can instantaneously change a face.
The software references points on the model’s
face to maintain the projection during movements
- altering it from makeup or paint to more
advanced reflections and digital designs.
And they’re looking for ways to implement
this in movies and games.
Finally, Arc Attack controls an arpeggiator
with Xbox Kinect which outputs midi to a tesla
coil to make music.
I’m gonna leave you with a thousand-robot
swarm that self-assembles into shapes and
as always - thanks for watching.